hey everyone this is Steve Weintraub
with collider and uh I'm here obviously
in the collider Studio at Sundance which
is being sponsored by Saratoga spring
water and I just want to give them a
huge thank you because attending
Sundance is very expensive and I really
appreciate our sponsors so thank you
um I'm it's also dehydrating sir yeah
yeah you're basically like you're
basically on an airplane at all times in
Park City God that's a really good thing
to remember yeah it's but I'm being
completely serious oh wait are you right
exactly and I'll be honest with you and
I'll say it uh sometimes sponsors you
know you don't exactly align but their
water is actually pretty good yeah
that's great what is great serotonin no
I'm talking about like their specific
one and I you know what it is it's
because of the bottle like it's not
plastic
by the way listen I I appreciate this
because like I said and I'm not joking
it's really expensive for me to bring
the crew here and to put this on
absolutely and sponsors are really
important just like for it's like you
know the financing to make your movie
financing for me to be at Sundance
people the same way because
you'll like dream into a realistic place
and you really need the pragmatic people
and the people willing to like share and
give you that chance who don't want to
um uh control it you know either it's
like so that's so special and rare and
cool I felt like we had that yeah so
listen we're here to talk about bad
behavior uh and I really have so many
questions for your feature debut
um but every time I see that gentleman
sitting right there one of my all-time
favorite movies is Cloud Atlas yeah and
I just always want to bring it up so
more people will see it and I just want
to sort of commend you on that role and
the film and uh that's really half if
you want to say anything about it by all
means but I just want to say how awesome
it is uh just wonderful to hear you say
that and I love that film very much too
yeah you know
it seems to every year find
more and more
devotees I think I feel like slowly
slowly I think it got a bit of a bad
deal at the time it came out but I feel
a lot of people do discover things yeah
now after the after their release how
was your date to the premiere Alice was
my date today yeah and I loved it too I
thought it was awesome I agree first of
all it was amazing I had no idea when I
asked the question but I I think that
Lana did it's such an amazing film and I
think that you know it asks a lot of the
audience but it's so it's beautiful just
beautiful
yeah
maybe it's time is coming oh it's come
I'm I'm there you know what I mean okay
enough just again if you haven't seen
Cloud Atlas I recommend it
um so jumping into why I get to talk to
you guys um I I really want to say
congratulations on your movie and I
really want to commend getting any movie
made as a miracle and getting your first
feature made that you've written and
directed so I start at the beginning for
the audience that won't have seen it yet
like what have you been telling people
about it like your friends and family
when they say well what's your movie
about
um I think I usually tell them like
friends and family I don't put a lot of
effort in to be honest because I know
that they'll have to find out about it
but here at like the festival and
whatnot I think it's really about
um someone who's
trying to find their hero's journey and
really deviating from that and kind of
exploding any opportunity to be
sympathetic but still coming to like a a
place that feels real and maybe more
useful
uh then I know you must be offered um
I'm going to say at least a script or
two every once in a while and so I am
curious well for the audience can you
talk about who you play and what was it
about the material that said I want to
do this I play a character called Elon
Bellow and Elon is a spiritual
uh teacher forward slash Guru and he is
an enlightened human and he's written
books about
what it means to be enlightened and how
someone else might Attain enlightenment
and
um and people are attending his retreat
um including the central character
played but absolutely sensationally by
um Jennifer Connelly
um and Jennifer Connelly's characters
called Lucy and Lucy is on Elon Bellows
uh
silent Retreat although it quickly isn't
silent any longer
semi-silent it's actually quite a lot of
noise yes
um going on on the return and I I was
drawn to the material
well it's hard to talk about it because
me and Alice have known each other a
very long time she's a very very dear
friend and I've been I was in Alice's
short film family happiness
and we've shared lots of my and we
actually nearly did another film shangan
princess
and so this was so when this came
through I was very excited because I was
like wow this is this is this is Alice's
first completed
feature script and I was just blown away
by the writing
by the kind of God the kind of amazing
Insight that she brings to
people to relationships and her
incredible
sense of the absurdity of
just about everything and silliness and
profundity all mixed up together so I I
was just delighted and it felt so fully
realized
that even if she had not been a very
different I think I would have well I
know I would have done it you know it's
just brilliant piece of writing you
you've obviously worked with a number of
directors and I'm curious what did you
learn from the various filmmakers you've
worked with that you stole for your
directing debut as a feature and what
were some like was there anything that
you're like I am never going to do this
on my set
oh oh God that's such a good question I
think like one of the things I stole was
never to try to get it right or try to
get it perfect but just to always be
interested in what space was working and
that gives you a lot of room to play
because if you start trying to repeat
something you just you just become
self-conscious and it's not really the
it takes you so far away from what being
present as a performer really is which
is like you have to somehow navigate
that
meta world of you know
um yeah you just I just don't ever want
to lock anyone down I just want them to
feel free because when you work with
people like Ben and Jennifer they're so
insanely talented and deep and they have
so much knowledge and so much like
electricity in them and you just don't
want to think that you're you know you
don't want to be in the business of
trying to be smarter than anybody else
like I just love I love being a fan of
people and it was really fun to just be
able to try and enable everyone to
enjoy what they were doing when you get
a chance to do it and I really think
it's you don't need to you don't need to
I really think you don't need to punish
people to get good performances from
them I think sometimes like we think
that there's a certain kind of
personality that comes with
um an author or with
um talent and I think that that's
completely untrue I think that sometimes
that that stuff that kind of aggression
that um domination is is something that
kind of uses the talent as an excuse to
keep going and I think that's
something I really don't want to
do
or experience yeah and I've worked with
so many directors who don't do it and it
was beautiful and it was still raw and
hard and deep and interesting
um but you know it just you don't
you don't get a huge therapy bill from
it like why you don't I don't think it's
necessary no it definitely is not
everything's already like weird and hard
enough like you obviously had to make
this on a budget and I'm curious what
was what when you looked at the schedule
and you saw how many shooting days you
had what were you most nervous or what
you know what I mean about the
challenges of pulling this off on the
schedule
you know what it was I just had to
believe that we were enough and that
we
like anything that was a mistake or
anything that would go wrong would
instead have to be taken as an
incredible plot twist because we had a
very small schedule and you know we did
not have the biggest of budgets and I
got covered on the first day I've got
covered on the first day of shooting the
film and so I directed the opening
scenes
with like a gentle fever rising from my
bedroom of a zoom with terrible
connection and it was such an incredible
trust exercise and I remember seeing
like Jennifer on the screen and knowing
that you know I know you can't make a
movie for everybody though I'm actually
like amazed at how many people really do
love our specific crazy unusual being
of the movie but I remember knowing that
I could see the movie I wanted to make
when I saw Jennifer come through that
and it was
also a reminder how like let people do
their jobs you don't need to be on them
all the time like
like ask how long did you actually
coveted how long were you I was so lucky
it wasn't bad so we just you know we
just did the the government prescription
and I was really luckily also not having
long covered so when you know I'd done
my time I was able to return and I
actually felt like I I don't know maybe
it was just so exciting to actually get
to go into the set maybe because
freaking movie it was like I'm still I
still feel like I'm can't believe any of
this has happened and thank you for you
know being so interested and talking and
all that it's really cool not only
directed everyone else you also
miraculously it seems to me somehow
directed yourself
because Alice is also an incredible
incredibly important role in the film
and like giving uh also a sensational
performance but how did you how did you
find it
I want you to ask her questions because
you have a different perspective on the
entire craft than I will ever have and I
and your Insight is probably you know
you know what I'm sorry to ask questions
no I want you to ask questions please as
you haven't had the opportunity to ask
you what it was like to direct yourself
I've noticed that sometimes in
interviews people ask you stuff and you
say
okay I don't know hi
and I really just was like damn I would
have motor-mouthed all over that
question yeah
I know some stuff but I don't really
know like I sort of just looked at other
people's faces because I'm pretty good
at knowing if they're like
hating it you know it's interesting but
I knew I just felt like I had an
instinct for it and I I did want to
I was really interested in
uh trying to make it feel
like personal and real as a story and I
didn't want to force
actors to into telling the story or to
be in a position with anyone over Dylan
and I knew I needed to be really really
be there for Lucy as well and I knew I
could
I don't know I just knew I could
respect Jennifer and you know in in her
power and that I could be
I just I don't know yeah mate I don't
know what the hell I don't know what I
expected to hear yeah I don't know I
just looked at Desiree and Molly's face
and be like okay I think it's all right
and then just try everything yeah you
know
try at all I don't want to do any
spoilers at all because no one has seen
the movie but um
and I might edit this out if you don't
want me to run it but like there's a
there's a like a a thing that happens in
like the second act that I was not
prepared for I was it it was you know I
don't want to give anything away but
it's a big moment in the movie yeah did
you how early on did you know that you
wanted that that was from the very
beginning from the very beginning
um
I I wanted to say like this this person
was so so in need of escaping their ego
and their story and I've noticed that
sometimes you know your mind gets really
quiet when you are so embarrassed and
ashamed of yourself that it's like your
ego it's like a publicist it doesn't
can't think of anything to say anymore
doesn't want anything to do with you
it's like you're hopeless like let's get
out and it's suddenly quiet and it's
like in these moments with feel of deep
failure where you go oh oh that's right
this is what life's all about and then
once things go well again you start to
get old get into yourself again so I
really really wanted to see somebody
try to navigate
the story of their life their ego and
when they can't win that like arm
wrestle they're just like well I'm
[__] taking it I'm taking I'm taking
us both down and to think and just to
see what was left in like that wreckage
you know 100
um I I don't uh generally talk about
other family members but um you have a
family member that's a kind of a
talented uh filmmaker just a little bit
and I'm just curious how nervous were
you to show your mom the film for the
first time
well she'd read the script
um a while ago I showed her like when it
was finished and about to be finished
and she was really supportive of it and
so I was nervous and then I was nervous
again because she tends to be pretty
brutally honest which I really respect
because
um
I wouldn't want anything else really
like
in
it would have been even more confusing
growing up in this industry if there
wasn't if she wasn't
you know giving her Integrity yeah
um
and she she she loves it so I'm happy
yes you know
um I really I was nervous but I was also
excited because I knew that the film was
hopeful even though it's so it's like I
know it's a satire but it's it's it's
sincere as well like I know that it's
hopeful and
um of course
yeah I am I I know Lucy says never give
it to her and then you say but I'm quite
a hopeful person yeah you are in my
downfall
um I I want to ask you an individual
question that actually doesn't have to
do with this movie
um like the entire planet I absolutely
adore and love the Paddington movies I
think they're masterpieces both of them
and I know that there's a third one
being made so what can you tell people
about it
really very little because I haven't
read this script
and I don't even know when we're due to
shoot it or
well
I I don't know I thought it would be
happening by now but I don't know maybe
there's it's gone it's gone silent in
the way that sometimes these things do
maybe that's
just means they're still working on it
or maybe it means it's not happening or
you just don't know I wonder if it's
because Paul is involved in um the Wonka
movie
yeah it might be but well no it wouldn't
be because Paul is not sadly anything to
do with well I wonder if he's like
producing or writing or he might he
might not have some involvement on that
level yeah but he's definitely not
directing you know this one yeah and I
have to just if you don't mind like do
you do you realize how many people
though those movies are amazing like are
you aware of that have you paid
attention
yeah I I I I I love them too and I see
that they really
affect people and
um
yeah I do I love that um I I'm very
happy that it's
so um so close to people's hearts it's
great I think yeah I'm not sure if
you've seen them
yeah there it is there it is okay oh
dear right I thought you guys were
friends what happened you went to the
premiere you haven't seen it
you haven't seen a single one of them
right here's the microphone because I'd
like to make sure we get it on record
not a single one
I have no official comment
home from ADR a whole day of ADR where
you had just been making
um Paddington Bear
um growling noises some days I just go
in and do like about 30 or 40 different
growls
she's like the whole day
you get the list of things you have to
do and you guys tiny growl
or Berry growl small disappointed growl
I'm obsessed with that all right well no
more sometimes I'm going home I'm gonna
watch Bangtan I do actually hear it's
great I'll produce who was saying she
watched it the other day a moment of
deep stress and it made everything
better they are they're delightful truth
again I I yes and the other thing is
that um uh it's great for like it's a
family move like everyone can watch it
everyone you know what I mean but I'm
jumping back into you
um I am curious now that you've done
your first feature how do you have like
scripts in the in the desk that you're
thinking about like how what are you
thinking about for are you thinking
about another feature I've two things
that I want to write I I wrote something
to give
um Marlon who plays Elmore in bad
behavior which is in his own way a
family film too
um I I wrote a fantasy story for him to
work with because he was obviously
playing an actor who was playing a role
and and I got a bit carried away and
wrote the whole film
but I that tickles me occasionally and
there's something else I like but
there's nothing to say I'm just gonna go
go for it yeah on my own and see how I
feel better to do it that way yeah yeah
um I would love to talk more
specifically about this film and
Jennifer's fantastic performance
she's such a talented actor and she's so
good in this yeah
um and one of the reasons she's so good
is because you directed well being sick
with covet you know I'm I got out of her
way I'm being serious she's she's so
good but uh because no one has seen it
yet I don't want to get specific yeah
and this is so kind of yes
I love I love Jennifer Love because I'm
so I'm I'm so into her as well I just
think she's incredible it's so nice to
meet people and she's also been she's
fantastic for so long forever always
like um but she you know you just
believe when she's on screen that she is
this person oh no it's like it's she you
know it's not acting it's just she is
the person yeah you know that's also
pretty good you're also pretty good as
an actor you know I'm talking about
Jennifer right it's all about it's all
about it we love we love yeah we love
Jennifer yeah we're
yeah yeah
she's uh disciples yeah she's sorry you
want to go to her cult
um when down the road when the film is
actually coming out we will talk more
and get more specific but I'm just going
to say on that note I hope you have a
fantastic Sundance this guy owns
Sundance this year I think he even has
another movie he does we're going to see
it tomorrow yeah the passages the
premiere is tomorrow yeah you know um so
you know he lives a tough life it's very
tough
um on that note I'm just going to say a
sincere thank you for coming in and I
really do hope Paddington 3 happens but
only if it's as good as the first two I
know that's the
maybe that's why it's being delayed a
bit it's a big their big shoes to feel
feel aren't they yeah 100
um totally worth seeing on that note
thank you so much Saratoga and everyone
for watching our Sundance interviews
thank you thank you thank you Steve